I'm a chemist and therefore I suppose
the most obvious number for me to talk
about is Avogadro's number and
Avogadro's number is very big
surprisingly although I'm a chemist I
can never remember the exact value so
let me just look it up it is six point
zero two two one four and there's some
argument the further decimal places
times 10 to the 23 so this is a very
very big number and it is related to
atoms and molecules so Avogadro was an
Italian chemist who worked at the
beginning of the 19th century and
shortly after John Dalton had proposed
the idea of atoms Avogadro was thinking
of the number of atoms and molecules
inside the flask a bit like this one so
you mention the gas inside here from
those ideas he developed their
hypotheses about the number of molecules
of any gas inside a flower but it's
easier for me to explain it to you with
some atoms here so imagine that we have
here hydrogen carbon which is black
oxygen and uranium which is big after
the time of Avogadro
people started measuring the relative
mass of these atoms so hydrogen has a
mass one carbon-12 oxygen 16 and uranium
these are four particular isotopes these
weights are defined by the number of
protons the positively charged particles
and neutrons the neutral ones in the
nucleus so for example in carbon you
have six protons and six neutrons
whereas in uranium you have 92 protons
and I can't work out the number of
neutrons but they add up to 238 I'll
leave that for you to calculate
later chemists took avocados idea and
developed it into the statement that if
you take one gram of hydrogen 12 grams
of carbon 16 grams of oxygen or 238
grams of uranium the number of atoms in
that sample would be exactly the same
and that number was given the name
Avogadro's number
in honor of Avogadro who started
thinking about these things in the first
place
professor is that fact a lovely
coincidence or is there inevitable that
would have happened because of the way
the weights buttons work this is
inevitable it's nothing it's not a
coincidence it's not just like that the
the number of my birthday December the
16th is the same as the mass of oxygen
it's something that's inevitably true
because of the way that these mass scale
has been done it is the relative masses
of the different atoms the big question
is how can you actually work out what
the number of this these atoms are
because there's so many of them you can
easily say that even a simple experiment
that you could do at school or college
will tell you it's 6 times 10 to the 23
but it is the decimal point and the
numbers after the decimal point that are
really the key and the more numbers you
can measure the more precisely you knows
the number now you can ask what's the
point of measuring these things so
precisely why do we want to know this
number so precisely and the reason is
that it has become very important in
recent years for the definition of the
unit of mass the kilogram as you know we
have a whole series of fundamental units
the second the meter and so on the
ampair so you can define most of these
units such as the
meter in terms of the speed of light but
what do you use the kilogram now there's
still some argument but one approach is
to say if we could define a brigade rose
number then we could relate that to the
mass of carbon 12 or whatever and then
this would become a fundamental constant
and we would no longer have to rely on a
lamp of platinum or iridium stored in a
vault to define what we mean by a
kilogram the way that people are
approaching this is to measure the mass
of a lamp of silicon the reason they've
chosen silicon is because it is an easy
or relatively easy material to handle
and purify so they have made a spherical
lamp
imagine now this is a real ball about
the size of the one I'm holding but made
out of silicon and very special silicon
the isotope silicon 28 so that's just
one isotope of silicon and they have
grown a single crystal of silicon 28 and
then machined it into a spherical ball
and using this ball because you can
measure its diameter and you can measure
the using x-rays the distance between
the layers of atoms you can calculate
the number of atoms in the ball you
can't get to the nearest atom but all
being well they may be able to get to
one part in 10 to the minus 8 that means
effectively they can measure the number
will calculate the number to 9
significant figures that's six points
and then eight numbers and each of those
digits they can be certain is right it's
a long way off
but it's near enough to define the
kilogram as accurately as people want it
might be worth giving an idea how big
six
times 10 to the 23 really is and one of
my friends Colin Johnson has calculated
and I haven't checked his calculation
that if you went round the entire coast
of the UK and on every Sandy Beach used
an excavator to remove all the sand to a
depth of one meter and then you piled
all that sand up somewhere and then
counted the number of grains of sand it
would be about six times ten to the 23
so if you took a lump of gold just
slightly less than 197 grams which
because Gold's dense is not very big
probably much smaller than any of these
balls in that lump there would be the
same number of atoms as in this huge
pile of sand that you've got from
excavating all the beaches to a depth of
one meter so you get the idea it's a big
number
the other thing is that most chemists
don't use that Vergara's number very
often but what they do use is the unit
that is called a mole and a mole is
Avogadro's number of molecules and they
talked about reactions very often in
terms of moles now some of you may know
that in English and American English
mole is the name of a small furry
creature that burrows under the ground
and in America every year they celebrate
chemistry on so called mole day and they
have all sorts of cartoon moles that
tries to make people enthusiastic about
chemistry I appear on YouTube quite
frequently but not on this channel but
on Brady's other Channel the chemistry
channel called periodic table of videos
and we have a lot of fans and last year
on mole day a fan in a school in Seattle
produced a mole
she's called Melinda and she's in Honors
Chemistry 3a that's the girl not the
mole yes and she called this mole that
she made molten Moliere cough and I
think is rather sweet and some of you
who have a good imagination may think
that there's a vague resemblance between
the mole and me I think it's great that
young people like Melinda get so
enthusiastic about chemistry and our
channel that they make models like this
and I would encourage you even if your
maths buff have a look at our chemistry
channel because chemistry is more fun
than you think and it has bigger
explosions than on land
look at me
I'm just gonna check if there's none
left